A stunning
new court
filing shows Fox anchors and executives
privately ridiculed former
President Trump's lies
about the election,
even while promoting them on air.
The revelations are part of Dominion
Voting Systems
$1.6 billion lawsuit against Fox.
And CNN's
Brian Todd is digging into the damning
testimony and messages.
So tell us more, Brian.
Pamela, these messages
reflect real angst and conflicts
within the top
echelons of Fox News right after the
2020 election as well.
As a hefty dose of hypocrisy.
Immediately after Joe
Biden's 2020 victory,
Fox News
hosts were unabashed
in promoting the false declarations
that the election had been stolen
from Donald Trump.
Electronic voting machines
didn't allow people to vote, apparently,
and that whatever
you think of it, the cause of it
it shakes people's faith in the system
that is an actual threat to democracy.
It will be impossible to ever know
the true fair accurate election results.
But tonight, a new court
filing shows that in private,
Fox host Tucker
Carlson, Laura Ingraham and Sean Hannity
were brutally ridiculing
the claims of election fraud
and the people who were making them
their private messages in a legal filing.
That's part of Dominion Voting Systems.
$1.6 billion lawsuit against Fox News
one person they insulted.
Trump campaign lawyer Sidney Powell,
a vociferous election line promoter.
What we are really dealing with here
and uncovering more by the day
is the massive influence
of communist money
in one text revealed in the court filing.
Tucker Carlson texted
Laura Ingraham saying quote,
Sidney Powell is lying.
I caught her.
It's insane.
Ingraham responded, quote,
Sidney is a complete nut.
No one will work with her.
Ditto with Rudy.
A reference to Trump lawyer Rudy
Giuliani and his post-election claims
there was a plan from a centralized place
to execute
these various acts of voter fraud.
In other messages,
Sean Hannity said Giuliani
was, quote, acting like an insane person.
Ingram described Giuliani as an idiot.
Fox Corp.
Chairman Rupert Murdoch
We still have freedom of speech.
Said it
was, quote,
really bad
that Giuliani was advising Trump.
They have one version of the world
that they keep to themselves.
And another version of the world
that they broadcast to the viewers.
The two are entirely incompatible.
But Fox kept promoting
election denialism.
Why the filings in the Dominion suit
illustrate that Fox executives
were worried
about losing viewers to Newsmax,
a smaller conservative channel
that was constantly pushing
election denial.
Trump
himself furious that Fox had called
Arizona for Biden, Arizona.
11 electoral votes
had encouraged his followers
to switch to Newsmax since 2002.
Fox News
has basically been the preeminent
ratings champion in cable news.
And you see here the moment that they see
any sign
that might be slipping away it's panic.
But the Dominion filings
also say that
when then-President
Trump tried to call in
to Fox on January 6th,
the day his supporters attacked
the Capitol Fox executives
refused to put Trump on the air.
Fox News has
denied Dominion's
claims in the lawsuit
says its proud of its 2020
election coverage
and says
these court
filings contained
Cherry-picked quotes lacking context.
In a statement, Fox
accused Dominion of generating,
quote, noise and confusion
and said The core of this case
remains to be about freedom of the press
and freedom of speech. Pamela.
All right, Brian Todd, thanks so much.
I want to bring in
CNN senior media reporter Oliver Darcy,
along with Maggie
Haberman of The New York Times.
She is also a CNN political analyst.
So, Maggie,
these court documents,
they reveal a stunning level of hypocrisy
on the part of FOX.
What does this reveal about
just how strong of a grip
the former president had on the network?
It's it's quite striking.
And you saw this evolution over time.
Rupert Murdoch had always
wanted to be close to a U.S. president.
He got that
when Donald Trump was elected,
even though they really did
not have much of a relationship
to speak of Rupert Murdoch
and never thought very highly of him.
But by the time he was in office,
there was a synergy.
And Fox
clearly saw a benefit in terms of viewers
and ratings in staying close to Trump.
What I was very struck
by, Pamela,
was this claim in the suit
that Trump had tried to get on Lou Dobbs
after the riot had had taken place
but was not totally done yet.
This was new information
that hadn't been uncovered at any point
the last couple of years.
I do think it's also striking
how the opinion hosts had such sway over
what was being broadcast news wise.
And it's just
it's really jarring noticing
how Donald Trump is not on Fox right now.
I wonder what that will look like
in the future as he remains a candidate.
Yeah,
it is really jarring on
so many fronts here.
What do you think, Oliver?
I mean,
how much do you think this was motivated
by a desire
to appease viewers
and preserve television ratings?
These texts
and communications are very telling.
I think it was entirely motivated
by the business decision, which was that
they did not
want to alienate their audience.
And their audience
was listening
to Trump, was listening to Rudy
Giuliani, was listening to Sidney Powell.
And they wanted to believe
that the election was stolen from him.
They wanted to believe that
Joe Biden was not the rightful
president elect at the time
and that this election
could be overturned to Donald Trump.
And so the Fox News hosts and executives,
they couldn't have people on air,
you know, going
contrary to this narrative
that was being pushed
by the former president.
And so what you see here is that they are
they are,
you know, desperate
to appease the audience.
You see in text messages
behind the scenes where they talk
about
not offending the audience,
respecting the audience,
and in their eyes, I guess respecting
the audience is not telling them
inconvenient truths.
I would argue that respecting
the audience is being upfront with them
about what they knew.
And these text messages show
that they knew
the election was not stolen,
but they were happy to prop this
narrative up anyway.
Yeah.
I mean, the job of
just telling the truth,
that seems to be the best way to
respect your audience.
It is pretty, pretty
stunning when you look at it that way.
And we knew at the time
I remember
seeing that, that more and more
when you look at the ratings of Newsmax
at the time, more and more people
were turning there.
That, of course, as we see
we see now inside the panic at Fox.
And that was happening and Maggie,
you just mentioned that
that new information,
I think all of us who covered the Trump
White House
and especially you who covered Trump
so closely over the years,
the fact that Fox executives
refused to put Trump on the air
when he called in
after the January six attack.
I want to talk to you more about that.
What do you think that reveals
about Trump's state of mind?
Well, I think a couple of things.
I think that it reveals the Trump
state of mind was about just being heard
and speaking despite
the fact that this violence
had taken place.
I don't know what he was going to say,
but I think that we can guess,
given the themes of that day
and that he didn't
seem willing
to relent in everything
that we have learned since then.
Even though he finally issued
a statement publicly.
In terms of the minds
of the Fox executives,
I think that they were
you know, I have to surmise
that they were aware
that Trump had been tweeting
about Mike Pence,
that he had been talking about Mike Pence
at the rally
at the Ellipse
before this this pro-Trump mob
overtook the Capitol.
And they were concerned about being seen
as adding to that.
And that speaks to, again,
the concerns that that Trump really was,
you know, gasoline on
a fire in that moment.
Yeah.
And yet
Oliver, when a reporter at FOX tried
a fact check
that communications
show, the Fox
executives and host weren't too happy.
No, not happy at all.
And it's not just any host
it's the top rated host on this network.
You have Tucker Carlson
reaching out to Sean Hannity saying,
can we get her fired?
You have Sean Hannity
saying he's in contact
with the Fox News CEO Suzanne Scott.
And apparently the message did
get down to the reporter,
Jacqui Heinrich,
who ultimately deleted her tweet
and then reposted
another version of the fact check.
But it's really striking
to see that
the people
who are running this network
and the people who are Fox
executives are in line with
are not the news
that the news anchor like Rap Bear,
it's the it's the propagandists
like Sean Hannity and Tucker Carlson.
Very disturbing. Oliver Darcy.
Maggie Haberman, thank you.